[Music]
this is a special edition of your money
briefing for Friday April 21st I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
welcome to the fourth episode of our
series under contract your guide to home
buying on today's episode we're talking
about common mistakes that can
short-circuit the home buying process or
in some cases results in a disastrous
experience it can be heartbreaking for a
prospective home buyer particularly for
a young family that's buying a home for
the first time you've worked very hard
to bring together the financing to make
sure that you have the Savings in place
as you're approaching that closing date
to get an inspection report back or an
appraisal back that doesn't quite fit
one homeowner will meet thought she'd
done everything right but still ended up
incredibly dissatisfied when I first
moved in I just had this feeling that I
didn't like it I couldn't tell why but I
think later I realized it's because the
black mold and the asbestos even though
they've been certified that they're now
gone they're clean in the back of my
head I still feel like it's still there
so I didn't feel safe we'll hear more of
her story in a moment but first to
discuss mistakes and setbacks that can
often plague the home buying process is
Sam Chandon founding director of the
Chen Institute for Global real estate
Finance at New York University hey Sam
thank you for being with us delighted to
be here
so Sam buyers have been in Fierce
competition with each other for several
years now what are the biggest mistakes
you see and how they make the initial
approach to the buying process the first
thing that we see is that buyers May
misjudge where we are in the real estate
cycle and for most households this is
going to be the most significant
investment that they'll ever make and so
understanding fully where we are in that
real estate cycle whether or not there's
the potential for prices to decline
significantly over the course of the
coming months over the coming years and
what importantly may happen with the
cost of financing the mortgage rates
both very very critical for prospective
buyers particularly first-time buyers to
be thinking about when they're entering
that market but overall we can
reasonably expect this is a long-term
investment and so timing it correctly
becomes terribly important not only when
we're thinking about our timing in the
real estate market but also in thinking
about where we are in our household's
life cycle it may be the case that a
change of job in the next couple of
years will require that we relocate to
another city it could be that we're
expecting a significant change in terms
of the size of our household it could be
that as an early stage household I'm
expecting to start raising kids it could
be as a late stage household that I'm
expecting to find myself as an empty
nester at some point in a couple of
years but thinking about these two life
cycle issues where are we in the real
estate cycle and what does that mean for
prices what does it mean for borrowing
costs given that this is a long-term
investment but on the other side of it
also thinking about where I am as a
household and what my long-term needs
are going to be buying in a way that
anticipates those long-term needs all
right so let's focus in now on the point
where a prospective buyer finds the
house they'd like to buy it's an
accomplishment to get to that point but
they probably have competition so what
should buyers keep in mind with regard
to the bidding process the most
important thing for buyers to keep in
mind is that they should remain within
their budget this is a long-term
Financial commitment that they're taking
on ideally buyers will have already
explored their different options in
terms of the availability and cost of
financing and an important part of that
includes mortgage pre-approval fully
understanding what kind of mortgage they
can carry but also evaluating when
assessing okay how much can I bid it's
not just your mortgage payment there are
all sorts of other costs associated with
being a homeowner they're the insurance
costs up front there are moving costs
there's the costs of inevitably having
to replace a roof or making another
significant capital investment in your
home you mentioned that buying a home is
one of the biggest expenses somebody
will take on in their lives why do you
think people are making mistakes at this
point for most American households this
will be the largest single investment
that they ever make and that really
underscores why it is that in this
environment in particular we need to be
very very careful in decisions about
where and when we're going to buy a home
for a lot of households the errors that
we see are really being driven by two
things on one hand it's a high-stakes
decision and it's being made in an
environment of considerable pressure you
combine that with a general lack of
experience for the first time home buyer
this is the first time that they're
entering this Market but even for a
repeat buyer this may only be the first
time in 10 years or 15 years that
they're navigating home buying so it's
not an environment in which we have a
tremendous amount of experience you
combine these two things the high stakes
of buying a home the lack of experience
and what you ultimately see is that home
buyers do a very good job of evaluating
the current situation the current home
buying opportunity how can I make this
work but we very often will ignore the
Alternatives that are available to us
when we come back we're going to shuttle
ahead further along in the home buying
timeline to a common trap where
perspective buyers often make a critical
mistake the inspection
[Music]
Stella Guan is in her early 30s and two
years ago in 2021 she wanted a fresh
start after deciding to sell her condo
on the east coast and move to California
she was one of the millions of people
who rushed into the housing market
looking for something new
so I bought a house in the suburb of La
in a town called Santa Clarita and I had
the plan to move to California a few
months back so I thought it'd be nice to
get a head start on my home buying
process by searching remotely I got
connected to an agent in La through my
previous agent in New Jersey so I
thought it's the perfect opportunity
because I have someone locally who can
look for me and I could do a video
viewing so I felt confident that this
could potentially work out did you
actually see the house before buying it
for the one that I ended up buying yes I
didn't see a few houses in person and
made an offer but I was rejected on all
of them but the one that I actually
ended up buying I did see it in person
and what did you learn about the house
after you moved in so I already know
that it had a few problems before I made
the offer but I thought they're fixable
so I learned that it has black mold I
also learned that there was asbestos in
the Attic that I needed to fix but I
thought the prize was right and it was
within my budget and the competition was
very Fierce and I desperately wanted the
house to settle down so I thought okay
it should be fixable and I got some
contractors to quote everything out for
me and it seems to be within my budget
all right so take us through this
timeline you're given the keys to the
house and what unfolded after that yeah
so it really took me by surprise because
I had spent about two months renovating
and repairing the house I hired a lot of
contractors and I spent a lot of money
and I was expecting that it would be
refreshed and I would be excited to move
in technically everything was done
everything was repaired so it should be
a shiny new house but but when I first
moved in I just had this feeling that I
didn't like it I couldn't tell why but I
think later I realized it's because the
black mold and the asbestos even though
they've been certified that they're now
gone they're clean in the back of my
head I still feel like it's still there
so I didn't feel safe when I was living
there for briefly just a few days and I
just feel this is all too much because I
was still paying down a lot of the
construction costs and I saw my bank
account just getting depleted day by day
while I have this concern in the back of
my head so I feel like the combination
has really affected my ability to
appreciate the house so what are the
lessons here how would you do things
differently next time I think it's
really important that if you
attached to it emotionally at all I
think I was definitely attached to it
because I was really trying to make it
work so I kind of ignored the hard
numbers and not to mention that I
actually got a loan that's rather
expensive that I need to keep paying
down and it all just kind of crashing
down on me is not worth it so I think
next time removing the emotional element
completely and just think of it as a
business deal as any deal that you would
do at work that would make it a lot
better Stella Guan thanks for being with
us thank you
and Sam chanton joins us again
you know Sam there's so much riding on
the potential purchase of a home the
next chapter of someone's life more
living space if they're planning on
expanding their family and for some
they're caught up in simply the momentum
of reaching the finish line but in
Falling in Love with a home people
sometimes lose sight of the possibility
that they may have to just walk away
exactly it can be heartbreaking for a
prospective home buyer particularly for
a young family that's buying a home for
the first time you know you've worked
very hard to bring together the
financing to make sure that you have the
Savings in place you've thought about
your moving costs you've thought about
depending on the jurisdiction you're in
the tax costs associated with buying or
getting a mortgage and as you're
approaching that closing date to get an
inspection report back or an appraisal
back that doesn't quite fit with all of
the careful plans that you've made it
could be really tough to have just take
a step back and start the process all
over again but it is critically
important to get that inspection report
done and when real issues arise that
either imply significant upfront costs
or significant costs that will be
incurred over the lifetime of ownership
that those be evaluated very very
carefully we don't want folks getting in
over their heads all right that's Sam
Chandon from the Chen Institute for
Global real estate Finance at New York
University Sam thank you very much for
being with us thank you so much
and next week we'll take a look at an
element of the home buying process that
often plays a direct role but is a
little more difficult to control the
psychology of buying a home well one of
the things that happens in just about
every area of investing or purchasing
decisions is something that we call fomo
which is fear of missing out this is
hardwired into our brains interest rates
are going up I'm starting to get anxious
should I buy now because when we become
emotionally charged we become rationally
challenged and the more emotionally
charged we are the more likely we are to
make a mistake and that's it for your
money briefing this week our producer is
mohsin Ali this episode was mixed by
Jess Fenton our supervising producer is
Melanie Roy and our executive producer
is Chris zinsley I'm your host J.R
Whalen thanks for listening and have a
great weekend
[Music]
thank you